let me use a yardstick to add and
subtract
really i'm going to be using a meter
stick to add and subtract but
let me talk to americans for a moment
five
plus four is 9.
watch this
plus 12 is 17 and i can say oh
plus
13 is 20 it adds and subtracts i'm not
telling you anything new what about
multiplying and dividing
there we go to logarithms
logarithms i can hear people saying oh i
hate logarithms i hate it oh
logarithms common logs
were created so that instead of
multiplying big numbers 751 times 982
what you would do is you'd take the
logarithm of 751
add it to the logarithm of 982
to get the logarithm of
something else the answer
look up the anti-log of that the
backwards log of that to get the result
so instead of
adding and subtracting numbers
on these two meter sticks if i replace
these
with logarithmic sticks
i can multiply and divide so i've got a
pair of meter sticks where i've covered
up a couple numbers
with
the log of that number the logarithm of
2 is
0.301 so i'm going to cover up 0.301
with 2. i'm going to cover up
0.301 with 2.
well the logarithm of 3
happens to be
0.48 more or less
oh cover that up look at this instead of
being nice and linear like this
all the numbers squeeze up over here
that's the way logarithms work big
numbers
squash up over here and they're real
nice and lazy out here let's see what
we've made here i know that i can add
distances let's try it now here's the
number two
here's the number two oh two times two
is four two
times three is six three
times three is nine it's multiplying
brady come on over here check this out
instead of having
a ruler like this
notice how
it's a ruler like
here here's two
three four five six seven
eight nine
and over here is 10 if you really want
to push on it
so here's the slide rule
and this scale over here
the d scale
is the important one oh pi is hiding hey
there's our friend pi
but this one also has
two
three
four
five
six
seven eight nine let me throw these
sticks away
and i'm only going to look at
these two scales here the c and the d
scales
let's just look at those let's go one
step further
let's use this cursor
times
is 8. okay
no surprise there and we can now go in
between numbers let's try something a
little bit more cool 2
times
two 2.1
two two point three two point four two
point five two point six two point seven
two point eight two point nine three
okay let's see two times
two and a half two times two point one
two point two two point three two point
four two point five
look at that
times 2.5 is
almost exactly 5. let's look at between
1 and 2 there's all these extra numbers
1.5 is over here but they didn't write
the 1.
a piece of tape
1.1
1.2
1.3 1.92
2.1 2.8
3.0 there's pi
1.2
times 2
is
2.12.2.3 2.4 okay it works
1.25 1.25
times
pi
is
3.92
about
i'll give it just a smidgen right in
here too
so
why do i even bother owning a calculator
well
this is nice it sits next to me you know
i can when i'm sitting here at my desk i
can multiply using a calculator
so
like everybody else i'm fairly lazy
let's fix this up just a little bit
better here put this over here
now i don't need to reach up here
anymore i can just say oh
i now have an electric slide rule
so when i want to multiply
or divide
oh
2.1 uh let's just move it back over to
here
two
times two
is four
all done electrically
but of course i need to move the cursor
too
let's multiply 8
times four
oh
oh eight times four
is a little bit more it looks like 32
it's either 3.2 or 32. the decimal place
i don't care about i'm just concerned
with the numbers slide rules don't know
about decimal places here's
51 52 53 54 50
55.5
times
three
to give oh 1.67
something like this
the latest advance in slide rule
technology
so i don't have as many as cliff but i
have various slide rules here i would
say this is my favorite and i'll tell
you about it sometime but now i want to
tell you about audible.com who have
supported this video
will have an epic range of titles no
matter what you're interested in for
example why not check out neville shoots
autobiography which is called you
guessed it slide rule shoot was an
amazing character not only a prolific
fiction writer but also an aeronautical
engineer and this book is the account of
his real-life adventures in the world of
aviation listeners to the podcast hello
internet which i co-host with cgp grey
may also be interested to know shoot has
a book called beyond the black stump and
yes that's also available on audible so
audible is offering a free audio book
with their 30-day trial go to
audible.com slash number file and you
can sign on for that 30-day trial you
can get your free book and if you use
the url slash number file at the end
they'll know you came here from the
podcast and when you get your free book
why not go for slide rule
by neville shoot
even you can even put it on your phone
you can listen to it when you walk the
dogs which is what i'm about to do now
yes you heard right i'm going to take
you for a walk yes yes you can go for a
walk as well yes brady check this out
how's the speed control i want to go
slow
i can go fast
want to go right way